this is a rectangle and yes this is a
rectangle
let's measure the green line below using
both rectangles and a centimeter ruler
so we have this green line and we're
going to measure in terms of rectangles
and we're going to measure on this ruler
and you immediately see the green line
is equal to one rectangle long but if we
measured in centimeters it's equal to
six centimeters long so we could say the
line is one rectangle long
but it's six centimeters long and that
makes sense because the rectangle is
much more than a centimeter it's
actually the length of a rectangle six
centimeters so the length of a rectangle
is longer than a centimeter you see that
this is the length of the rectangle it's
the same as a line while a centimeter is
this length the rectangle is actually
six centimeters long
so it takes blank rectangles then
centimeters to measure the line well
since the rectangle is longer it takes
fewer rectangles and centimeters to
measure the line
so it's fewer rectangles in centimeters
and you see that fewer rectangles one is
fewer than six it took one it only took
one rectangle to measure the line
because the rectangle's so long and it
took six centimeters to measure the line
so it took fewer rectangles than
centimeters to measure the line let's
keep going
all right
so we have
this is a rectangle yes that is a
rectangle
let's measure the blue line below using
both a rectangle and a centimeter ruler
so it's a similar idea
so when we look at this blue line the
line is now two of these green
rectangles long
so it is two rectangles long now in
terms of centimeters it is four
four centimeters long
four centimeters long the length of each
rectangle is
blank then a centimeter well each
rectangle is more than a centimeter it's
longer you see each rectangle is
actually two centimeters so it's longer
than a centimeter so it takes
blank rectangles and centimeters to
measure the line well since each
rectangle is longer it's going to take
fewer rectangles to measure the line so
we'll select fewer right over there and
you see that over here it only took two
rectangles to measure the line but it
took four centimeters two is fewer than
four
let's see
let's let's do one more of these
these are a lot of fun
all right this is a rectangle let's
measure the green line below same idea
the line is four rectangles long
the line is seven centimeters long
the length of each rectangle is shorter
or sorry longer than a centimeter you
see that right here each rectangle is
more than one centimeter so it takes
fewer rectangles or then centimeters to
measure the line so we've seen this
we've seen this multiple times